niemals wäre ich auf den gedanken zu
kommen mit jemanden sexuell
mich ein zu lassen in der hoffnung auf
berufliche privilegien oder vorteile bei
der miete bewegung geht es eben nicht
nur um mich und meine individuellen
erfahrungen sondern einfach empathie zu
entwickeln
für erfahrung von ganz vielen frauen die
ja auch ihre erlebnisse geteilt haben
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei 310 fragen wir
starten direkt mit der ersten frage ist
nach fast fünf jahren mit immer noch
alles beim alten wenn ihr sagt ja wir
stehen beim kampf gegen machtmissbrauch
immer noch so ziemlich am anfang dann
geht er jetzt bitte aufs grüne feld und
wenn er sagt nein eigentlich hat sich
durch mit two schon ziemlich viel
verändert einiges zum guten und anderes
vielleicht sogar zum nachteil lang könnt
ihr jetzt aufs gelbe zelt gehen könnt
euch jetzt gerne positionieren
[Musik]
jetzt wissen wir wo meine gäste stehen
aber wie würdet ihr dann auf dem feld
stehen sexuelle übergriffe
machtmissbrauch sexismus am arbeitsplatz
das millionenfach genutzt der hashtag
mit sollte weltweit die erfahrung von
frauen sichtbar machen den anfang
machten 2017 die enthüllungen um den
hollywood produzenten harvey meisten in
den usa und auch wenn die debatte zwar
schnell hier in deutschland gelandet ist
häuften sich die fälle erst so richtig
im letzten jahr der ehemalige
chefredakteur der bild julian reichelt
comedy-star luke mockridge und der
ehemalige intendant der berliner
volksbühne klaus dörr als sie verloren
ihre jobs aufgrund von metro vorwürfen
oder mussten sie zumindest pausieren und
auch in der musikbranche sorgte das
hashtag deutschrap metro für heftige
diskussionen
sind wir also noch ganz am anfang unsere
gäste sind sich uneinig aber wir suchen
hier bei 310 fragen ja ein kompromiss
deswegen bin ich gespannt ob die beiden
seiten sich zumindest ein bisschen heute
aufeinander zu bewegen werden und ob sie
sich auch auf die ein oder andere
errungenschaft aus den letzten fünf
jahren dann doch einigen können aber
jetzt erst mal an euch auf welcher seite
würdet ihr dann stehen sagt irgendwie
die grüne seite eigentlich ist alles
noch beim alten oder wie die gelben es
hat sich schon ziemlich viel getan
schreibt mir die kommentare ab jetzt
wenn ihr ein argument der anderen seite
zustimmt dann bewegt ihr euch ein
schritt nach vorne und wenn ihr
vielleicht auch während eine andere
person spricht das zum ausdruck bringen
wollte dass ihr das ganz anders sehen
oder wütend seid dann könnt ihr euch
einen schritt nach hinten bewegen karol
du hast zu beginn seiner beruflichen
laufbahn bei axel springer angefangen
und hat direkt dort machtmissbrauch
erlebt in welcher weise das ging von
sms e-mails damals gab es noch viel
facebook ich bin teilweise
auch über jahre mit dem chefredakteur
essen gegangen freitags weil man wurde
dazu aufgefordert man er wollte sich
blicken lassen in den schönen
restaurants der stadt wollte natürlich
für junge kolleginnen dabei haben und
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich auf das
unternehmen blicke wie es heute ist hat
sich daran sehr wenig geändert ich denke
wir treten beim mieten und sexismus am
arbeitsplatz immer noch auf der stelle
weil viele debatten oder viele klagen
von jungen frauen verharmlost werden
oder bagatellisiert werden da heißt es
schnell das war doch eine
einvernehmliche beziehung aber dieser
begriff ist eben grob irreführend weil
er eben völlig ignoriert dass eine junge
frau dieses machtgefälle ausgesetzt war
und auf gut deutsch das sie mit ihrem
chef ausgehen musste um ihren job nicht
zu verlieren und sie hat überhaupt keine
kein instrument sich dagegen zu wehren
in vielen betrieben gibt es noch nicht
mal eine beschwerdestelle und das da hat
sich wirklich sehr wenig getan mach's
noch einmal konkret erklären wie du zu
der erkenntnis kommt dass ich da noch
nicht so viel geändert hat an den
strukturen weil es diese fälle gibt es
gibt mehr fälle es gibt es gibt sie dort
dann muss ich nur aktuelle die presse
schauen und das passiert einfach jeden
tag dass sich junge frauen fragen in der
medienwelt oder auch in der freien
wirtschaft oder das wenn ich jetzt nicht
mit meinem chef abendessen gehe habe ich
dann noch morgen meinen job und das ist
wirklich eine existenzielle angst da
geht es um miete zahlen und kohle und um
überhaupt noch die ganze berufliche
laufbahn das sind gut ausgebildete
frauen die kommen nur aus dem studium
jahr abitur gemacht und denken so cool
jetzt werde ich für meinen für mein
match eingestellt und am ende sitzen sie
da und denken jetzt kann ich mir kurzes
kleid anziehen um mit dem arsch da essen
zu gehen entschuldigung und so hast du
dich selber gefüllt auf jeden fall der
serie wenn menschen dass das stichwort
hashtag nie zu hören dann denken ganz
viele direkt an hollywood an die
schauspielbranche wie waren es dann für
dich als junge frau in diese branche
eingestiegen was hast du da ähnliche
erfahrungen gemacht wie zum beispiel
caro natürlich überhaupt nicht alles was
eben gesagt wurde über journalistische
praktiken beispielsweise bei diesem wort
jetzt springer na dann gehen sie mal zum
theater am theater werden nicht wie beim
journalisten ereignisse und fakten
seziert sondern gefühle das heißt
theaterstücke emotionen liebe leid lust
begehren trennung verlieben ich nenne
das aus diesem grund weil das was als so
unerträglich dass man mit jemand essen
gehen muss ich meine tests ist
24 stunden der alltag einer
schauspielerin und als frau und das habe
ich gelernt habe ich jederzeit die wahl
mitzuspielen oder nicht mitzuspielen und
daher möchte ich doch auch die frauen
bitten sich dem gar nicht erst zur
verfügung zu stellen also es sind auch
gewisse punkte über die ich gerne noch
mal sprechen würde denn ich glaube wir
könnten mit einer korrekten attitude die
frauenbewegung sehr beschleunigen jede
frau hat die möglichkeit zu sagen ich
gehe nicht mit dem regisseur nachtzeit
12 in sein hotelzimmer sondern ich sage
wir sehen uns morgen am besten im büro
wo zwischen uns beiden ein schreibtisch
steht bitte rufen sie mein management an
ww kann jede frau einfach sagen nein ich
komme heute abend nicht mit ins
restaurant
also ich glaube
da spricht man oder sehe jetzt einfach
sehr aus einer privilegierten position
weil ich glaube nicht dass jede frau das
machen kann also wenn ich jetzt in einem
restaurant in und um meinen job fürchten
muss wenn ich da nein sagen
dann bringe ich mich ja in eine sehr
prekäre lage weil mein job dann
vielleicht drauf geht und ich dann meine
miete nicht mehr zahlen kann da sind
halt probleme die irgendwie existenz
gehen und das ist halt schon sehr
privilegiert dass so verallgemeinern ich
würde es nicht privilegiert nämlich nenn
es selbstbewusst niemals wäre ich auf
den gedanken zu kommen mit jemanden
sexuell
mich ein zu lassen in der hoffnung auf
berufliche privilegien oder vorteile
wenn jemand mit mir arbeiten will dann
betrachte ich dieses verhältnis rein
professionell arbeitsbezogenen und die
linie ich bin beides kann ja sein dass
mir jemand sogar gefällt umso besser
wenn mir der regisseur sogar gefällt und
ich möchte mit dem auch was zu tun haben
wenn er beispielsweise mein gärtner wäre
und ich mir keine vorteile beruflich
davon verspreche habe ich doch auch die
möglichkeit meinem herzen zu folgen also
das leben ist ja keine romantische
komödie und natürlich bleiben hier schon
gar nein nein aber ich meine nicht jede
frau kann nein sagen nicht jede frau
kann auch die man heiraten den sie will
wenn sie irgendwo auf dem dorf sitzt da
sind dann fünf typen und die haben
vielleicht traditionelle ansichten und
sie will ja vielleicht nicht wegziehen
dann ist das eben ihre auswahl ich meine
sie sind berühmt sie haben geld sie
können sich aussuchen was sie wollen im
leben nicht nur männer nicht nur top
angebote das hat nicht jede frau
natürlich also das ist eine eine reihe
babbel diskussion zu sagen ich kann mich
in den regisseur verlieben oder dass es
kann ja auch romantisch werden das ist
das ist doch das ist doch gaddafi hier
doch gerade das habe ich ja nun gerade
aus dem grunde genannt weil ich es nicht
so strikt regiere betrachte ich trenne
es nur in der sichtweise mein
berufsleben ist nicht mein privatleben
ich mache mich nicht zum opfer ich stehe
für alles zur verfügung ohne dass ich
etwas von mir her gebe was ich nicht
wirklich messstellen kleine modell ganz
mithalten vorher einen vorschlag machen
weil ich finde was ihr gesagt hat ist
total wichtig und auch nicht
wegzudiskutieren dass es wenn auch nur
das gefühl so ist so und ich würde es
gerne so richtig die differenzierung
findet
rausholen aus der ebene der persönlichen
entscheidung da sind wir nämlich schon
in einer situation die wenig hilfreich
ist diese persönlichen entscheidungen ob
sie privilegiert oder nicht privilegiert
sind delegieren die verantwortung am
ende auf den einzelnen und es gibt macht
asymmetrien vollkommen klar die kann man
weder wegdiskutieren noch macht das sinn
sieht so bagatellisieren usw und wenn
ich nochmal mein case machen dürfte
warum ich glaube dass sich in den
vergangenen fünf jahren was verändert
hat weil darüber mehr geschrieben
nachgedacht rapportiert recherchiert und
wenn wir google search angucken wollen
würde ich sagen da ist einiges passiert
also ich glaube mit who hat insofern
vieles verändert als auch viele tabus
und auch ängste
diese themen anzusprechen sexuellen
missbrauch belästigungen
erfreulicherweise weggefallen sind und
ich glaube das ist ein anfang es ist
aber noch nicht das wo wir hinkommen
müssen insofern bin ich gespannt wie es
weiter geht und jetzt komme ich zu der
eigentlichen veränderungen der
diskussion die ich anregen möchte wir
brauchen
einen rechtssicheren raum
der diese dinge so regelt und definiert
dass sich niemand in der situation
führen muss ob er jetzt super
unterprivilegiert ist oder super
privilegiert ist egal recht gilt für
alle gleichermaßen dass allein die
situation so ist dass man das gar nicht
jetzt zum ich muss mich jetzt
entscheiden ja oder nein sondern einfach
sagen kann das ist nicht akzeptabel so
und dann gibt es zwei formen von recht
die eine ist die klassische
rechtsprechung ich wurde immer so sagen
da gibt es schon hinweise aber viel
wichtiger ist dass sich die unternehmen
allesamt es geht ja nicht nur ist
sollten wenn ich nur beim medienriesen
es gibt es in jedem anderen unternehmen
und mittelständischen betrieb auch diese
themen
dass sich unternehmen eine compliance
wie das so schön heißt ja ein code of
conduct
auferlegen der absolut
unmissverständlich ist ich denke dass
mit diesem compliance rahmen der jetzt
geschaffen wurde das hat sozusagen ein
juristisches regelwerk in manchen
unternehmen wenn man es denn anwendet
darüber gelegt und das ist auch gut so
und das wird dazu führen dass es besser
wird aber was was ein großes problem
auch dieses also compliance bedeutet ja
dass frauen oder oberhaupt betroffene
jeden geschlechts sich sozusagen
beschweren können beim betriebsrat bei
der beschwerdestelle und es wird ein
juristisches verfahren ein internes
jüdisches verfahren eingeleitet einen
untersuchungs
ermittlungsverfahren was da genau
passiert ist das problem ist nur am ende
wie was ist die message oder was ist die
sichtweise auf die betroffenen in den
letzten monaten ist es so oft passiert
dass betroffene nachdem sie sozusagen
öffentlich gemacht haben das ist dass
sie ein mieter fall dass sie diffamiert
wurden dass sie auch von von gerichten
mundtot gemacht wurden und die message
an die jungen frauen da draußen ist
jetzt im grunde wir hören nicht zu nur
das wäre fatal das ist nur das ist ein
missverständnis gewesen wäre und ist
verteilen sie wäre aber es ist doch so
langsam bewegung einigen lasst uns sagen
es ist doch so gut er weil ich meine wo
hat eine betroffene in den letzten zwölf
monaten sagen wir mal wirklich feinsten
was ok in amerika waren auch eine andere
kultur herrscht aber wann hat sich eine
frau wirklich gut sozusagen aus dieser
lage in einem geschützten raum da
äußern können ohne das ist für sie
nachteile hatte ich meine ich bin
heutzutage noch als frau würde ich immer
noch sagen ich bin doch nicht bescheuert
ich fange erst was mit meinem chef an
und oder muss was mit meinem chef anfang
weil ich sonst ist ein dumme situation
komme für mich dann erzähle ich das auch
noch öffentlich und dann bekomme ich nie
wieder ein job weil ich dann daraufhin
diffamiert bin also ich meine welche
junge berufseinsteigerinnen würde das
heutzutage machen es ist immer noch die
message wenn du sowas erlebt äußern ich
besser nicht mich würde mal
interessieren was ihr denkt was hat sich
dann für euch verändert nach fast fünf
jahren metro schreibt mir gern mal
erfahrungen und gedanken in die
kommentare ihr habt euch alle vom grün
fällt ein klein wenig schritt auf uns
zubewegt seedorf vorher noch ganz kurz
vorher zu desiree deine augen gedreht so
dass ich hier fast ausgefallen sind
machst du noch mal sagen warum tut mir
leid da ist mir die mimik ein bisschen
entgleist weil ich habe die ganze zeit
nur ich ich ich ich gehört und bei der
miete bewegung geht es ja eben nicht nur
um mich und meine individuellen
erfahrungen sondern einfach empathie zu
entwickeln
für erfahrung von ganz vielen frauen die
ja auch ihre erlebnisse geteilt haben
und auch männer die es geteilt haben
aber vorweg natürlich frauen die es
geteilt haben und dass man dem ganzen
anerkennung schenkt und nicht die ganze
zeit das ganze wieder so dreht dass es
auf sich die ganze zeit bezogen ist das
ist total wichtig ich finde das
problematischste an der mito bewegung
ist einfach diese gnadenlose und brutale
wahrheit die einem da entgegen
geschmettert wird dass frauen die sich
in der öffentlichkeit dazu äußern
einfach immer mit victim bleiming im
anschluss zu tun haben das heißt sie
werden eigentlich immer als lügnerin
bezeichnet oder ihn wird nicht geglaubt
und das sehe ich als problematisch an
ich persönlich habe auch erfahrungen
gemacht wo ich mich selber behaupten
musste gegen männer die übergriffe sich
mir gegenüber verhalten haben und mir
unmoralische angebote gemacht haben und
ich habe nein gesagt und ich war sauer
ich war wütend und ich habe mich
behauptet und war selbstbewusst und
trotzdem als ich das dann in der
öffentlichkeit gesagt habe ohne die
namen zu nennen habe ich ein shitstorm
erlebt vom allerfeinsten ich wurde als
lügnerin betitelt man hat mir nicht
geglaubt ich habe nicht mal die namen
genannt und trotzdem ist die ganze
verantwortung auf mich abgewälzt worden
und das ist das was immer passiert und
auch was gerade passiert ist wenn wir
darüber reden dass die miete bewegung
einfach sensibilisieren soll wird der
fokus immer auf die frauen belegt warum
sie das denn jetzt machen warum sie sich
jetzt in die opfer position begeben
warum sie das erzählen so warum hört man
nicht einfach erst mal zu und erkennt
erst mal anders was passiert ist und
wenn man bedenkt dass nur fünf prozent
sich überhaupt trauen zur polizei zu
gehen und das ganze überhaupt zu melden
und 95 prozent sich das nicht mal trauen
muss man sich die frage stellen warum
trauen sich diese 95 das nicht das ist
doch der kern warum haben wir eine
gesellschaft in der eine frau sich nicht
trauen öffentlich darüber zu sprechen
weil die fälle die an die öffentlichkeit
kommen das ist ja ein bruchteil von dem
was passiert wirklich und das macht mich
einfach wütend dass man das dann einfach
auf sich bezieht weil es geht darum
glaube ich empathie zu entwickeln in
diesen momenten ja ich möchte dazu sagen
ich habe von mir gesprochen ja weil ihr
mich als privilegiert bezeichnet was ich
womit ich mich überhaupt nicht
identifizieren kann dass man natürlich
den blick auf die mehrzahl der frauen
lenkt das ist doch eine
selbstverständlichkeit
und deshalb sage ich ja auch gott sei
dank dass es hashtag niko gibt dass
diese debatte überhaupt mal zur sprache
kommen wird denn alles was in der
frauenbewegung frauen sich ein tera
erkämpft haben ist ein feld weil es ihm
nicht freiwillig von männern zugestanden
worden ist sondern es ist ein feld was
sie der der macht der männer abringen
mussten sie mussten mit durch durch
geschichtlich und durch viele beweise
sich erkämpfen als streiten und den
männern
abringen was eigentlich ihre
gleichberechtigung ist und das zieht
sich durch alle bereiche und das finde
ich eigentlich beschämend dass vom
geschenk gottes dem man als solchen den
frauen die ebenbürtigkeit nicht
freiwillig zugestanden wurde sondern ein
kampf erforderlich gemacht hat eine ich
würde gern noch mal dich ansprechen so
engagiert sich bei der yves rossy
bewegungen und setzt sich dort für
gleichberechtigung einen auch zum thema
toxische männlichkeit du sagst ein
problem beim aktuellen
gesellschaftlichen stand zum thema metro
ist dass wir nach fast fünf jahren
eigentlich immer noch keine ahnung haben
wo machtmissbrauch sexuelle belästigung
oder gewalt auch überhaupt anfängt an
welchen erkenntnissen machst du das
überhaupt machst du würdest das
festmachen quasi ich habe erstmal
natürlich auch persönlich weil ich ja
selber in so einem prozess benötigt mich
selber auch von dieser toxischen
männlichkeit das wort erst mal
anerkennen muss dass es das gibt und das
ist ein teil aller männlichkeit
konstruktion ist die in unserer
gesellschaft vorherrschend ist und
gleichzeitig sicher sei dass zum
beispiel wenn es fälle gibt wo
grenzüberschreitungen öffentlich gemacht
worden sind dass die reaktionen darauf
im prinzip klassische männlichkeit ist
männer müssen sich endlich nicht nur als
teil des problems was sie sind sehen
sondern als teil der lösung sie müssen
anfangen umzudenken sie müssen sexismus
verlernen und sie müssen vor allem
anfang zuzuhören denn alle diese dinge
stehen schon länger auf dem tisch aber
männer sind jetzt in der pflicht ihr
verhalten radikal zu verändern und um
endlich metro auch ein stück weit nach
vorne zu bringen wenn es in dem maße so
viele verschiedene fälle gab wo ein
erreicht mit praktika der mit
auszubildenden irgendwas hatte und er
dann immer sagt das ist quatsch und die
vorwürfe sind quatsch dann sagt das auch
irgendwas über die tat über die art und
weise mit welchem privilegien männern
immer noch durch die gegend laufen und
sagen können es war nix und ich bin echt
das große große opfer und was macht denn
der fall reichelt für dich deuten
deutlich also einfach verantwortung
übernehmen kultur verändern und wenn
wenn du mich fragst du würde ich sagen
ist es meine verantwortung dafür zu
sorgen dass das was du gesagt hast sich
so nicht fortsetzen kann sie sagen es
ist viel getan worden was genau also
ich kann ja nur ganz konkret für meine
verantwortungsbereich sprechen und wenn
du mich fragst und sage ich dir ganz
klar dass gibt einfach keine toleranz
für sowas und das muss gelebt werden es
muss von der führung vorgelebt werden
und man ist ja nicht als angestellter in
welchem angestelltenverhältnis auch
immer in einem rechtsfreien raum wir
haben sehr starken und auch wie ich
finde sehr engagierten betriebsrat wir
haben diese themen
sehr offen angesprochen schon vor dem
gerade geschilderten fall
da jetzt sehr viel wellen geschlagen hat
und die sensibilität ist auch schon sehr
viel länger da ich kann das vielleicht
aus einer persönlichen perspektive kann
ich das natürlich nicht nachvollziehen
porsche hat aber die die welt und die
zeitung ist jetzt auch nicht dafür
bekannt die sexistische und
feministische artikel zu schreiben die
die ganzen errungenschaft das ist falsch
also da kann ich nur empfehlen lesen sie
rebecca schönbach bei uns lesen sie
unsere sei die arabische kolumnistin
oder die kollegin die aus saudi arabien
nach deutschland geflohen ist die das
frauenthema
anspricht also diese thema gemacht
werden was mara delius anna lührmann
also wir haben so viele autorinnen und
autoren die dieses thema ansprechen ich
glaube da leben sie in sehr einfachen
zwei autoren genannt der schuldige
unterbreche die gegen gender gerechte
sprache angeschrieben der gerechte
sprache und machtmissbrauchs und zwei
verschiedene debatten die reden ja was
minister artikel ja aber vertraut sein
bis wir von alice schwarzer es gibt auch
feministische positionen ohne gender
sprache und ich glaube das muss man
einfach trennen wenn wir sagen wir
wollen
machtmissbrauch sexuelle übergriffe all
das ist ein wichtiges thema wenn man das
in einen topf schmeißt mit irgendwelchem
sprachlich ideologischen operationen
dann wird es ein bisschen schwierig alle
die frage an dich gerade schon
angesprochen in den usa beobachten wir
auf jeden fall dass es dort das ruder zu
einem ganz anderen verhalten auch in
denen unternehmen geführt hat manchmal
man fast das gefühl dass aus angst sehr
viel schneller reagiert wird als hier
und es gibt dort auf jeden fall
schneller konsequenzen als ja so sieht
man zum beispiel auch daran dass der
marktwert von unternehmen ziemlich
schnell sinkt alleine nur durch den mito
vorwurf warum funktioniert das in den
usa so viel besser als bei uns das glaub
ich kann nicht in der form gar nicht
beantworten ich glaube schon dass sein
also wir dürfen nicht vergessen wir
reden immer von nico aber die art
überweise und die themen über die im
rahmen von mir zugesprochen werden die
gibt es schon seit 2013 es gab ja damals
hinzu und ich finde ich die frage ist
insofern interessant
ich habe das gefühl dass deutschland ist
dann immer so ein bisschen weiter
weiterdenkt als wir dann eigentlich sind
und im internationalen vergleich belegt
deutschland zu den hinteren mittelfeld
platz gibt also von sagten ja schon
rechtsprechung ich bin der fall bei das
ist total wichtig aber wenn es zum
beispiel darum geht wie werbung
überhaupt mit den medien platziert wird
es gibt in spanien in norwegen jetzt
eine regelung sexistische werbung
verboten würde ich glaube die frage ist
warum das hier in deutschland nicht
passiert weil es ist wichtig dass wir
über rechtsprechung reden ist es wichtig
dass wir über compliance ist drin aber
das ist das ist doch das kann doch nicht
der endpunkt sein von dem hund begegnet
muss wir müssen uns auch die frage
stellen ein rainer brüderle 2013 hat
offensichtlich scheiße gebaut was mit
ihm passiert hat er irgendwie sein job
verlangt hat der ist immer noch irgend
welchen positionen so ein julian
reichelt dürft jetzt bei servustv wieder
irgendwelche sachen schätzen eine luke
mockridge hat danach direkt von sat 1
zum beispiel schutz bekommen und wie
wurde bereits nach einem show angeboten
so treten jetzt ist er wieder auf tour
zum beispiel so sammler hat danach
direkt nummer-eins-album gehabt so also
das darf man nicht vergessen ich würde
gerne mal wissen wollen wo das dann
aufhört wenn man sagt ja wir wollen auch
werbungen verändern also welche welt
steht am ende ich bin wirklich neugierig
welche welt ist am ende die welt die
sozusagen eine progressive nicht mit u
welt es würde mich wirklich eine frage
ist keine aussage interessant dass leute
bei einer frage zurück gehen also diese
diese äußerung das narrativ das wo wir
dann am ende nicht glaube wir werden am
ende noch als anderen welt leben wollen
das ist glaub ich klar dass da bin ich
mir sicher und das ist auch okay für mir
alle gemeinsam ich glaube sie haben
andere vorstellungen von dem wo wir
vielleicht auch land und mit welchen
schritten wieder landen ich glaube wir
sind uns aber einig dass es ein problem
gibt das will ich auf jeden fall
anerkennt das ist ja keine frage auf die
es eine ja oder nein antwort möglichkeit
gibt sondern es ist wo kommen wir denn
da hin wenn du jetzt werbung auch noch
bestimmen wollen glaube ich mich gesagt
ich habe wirklich gefahren die frage ist
wie definieren wir wo fängt sexismus und
dann wollen wir natürlich auch noch
verändern wollen wir das jetzt auch die
frage ist ja die frage wenn man
kulturhistorisch
auf die rolle
von rothe bei der darstellung des
menschen kann man von der höhlenmalerei
bis heute so ziehen wo wo fangen wir an
zu sagen da wird sexistisch dann können
wir unsere kulturgeschichte
dekonstruieren gibt ja auch
intellektuelle die das als interessantes
projekt haben ich glaube nur das sind
zwei verschiedene themen ich glaube was
sie sagen möchte das klima muss sich
ändern für frauen absoluten das absolut
da hat er auch sehr recht dass das waren
das geht um § 209 10 es geht darum die
körperliche selbstbestimmung von frauen
mit bleiben oder aber er so haben wir
mit mietern nicht mehr passiert muss das
ganze gesellschaftliche biotop sich in
der die ganze stimmung deswegen will ich
gern einmal kurz zu dem inhaltlichen
punkt von der anhöhe zurückkommen das
gesagt die konsequenzen sind oft also
gerade bei deutschen metro debatten
nicht es hin zu schwach was was sagt ihr
denn als gelbes fällt dazu ein
die konsequenzen sind in deutschland
ähnlich wie in amerika eigentlich immer
ein bisschen zu drastisch und
überzogen man hat doch in deinen oder
anderen stelle als der zug erst mal am
rollen war übertrieben und gab auch eine
ganze reihe von
selbstmorden von männern die
öffentlich an den pranger gestellt
wurden bevor überhaupt geklärt war was
genau passiert es einige die ihre posten
verloren haben haben das vollkommen zu
recht getan
es gab aber auch wirklich
echte opfer die nicht hätten sein müssen
ich möchte noch mal zurückkommen zu
rainer brüderle und laura himmelreich
die erste beleidigung gegen frontfrau
himmelreich aus sie hat die nämlich
wegen seines alters beleidigt woraufhin
er einen altherren move machten sehr
unreflektiert aber das würde ich ihm
auch gar nicht so wahnsinnig vorwerfen
wollen und mit einem kompliment
antwortete dass nicht mehr als
kompliment gelten kann weil er auf die
oberweite anspielte und das ganze ist
dann vollkommen verunglückt weil
himmelreich machte dann karriere und
brüderle war erledigt von anfang an war
die macht bei der journalistin nicht bei
herrn brüderle er war erledigt also das
was du gesagt hat stimmt sie war nicht
erledigt er war vielleicht vorher schon
erledigt aber der war nämlich dass man
diese beleidigung ist hier auf sein
alter und das ja nicht mehr politisch
prozent ist auch gemeint das muss man
genau nachlesen das sind würdest du reif
dabei würdest du reif dabei zustimmen
dass die konsequenzen teilweise zu hart
sind und deutschland das doch gleich
hart sind wie in den usa auf gar keinen
fall also in usa kam
mainz die jetzt für über 20 jahre ins
gefängnis ich glaube nicht dass das in
deutschland schon passiert ist jemals
und das gibt's für die großen fälle jörg
kachelmann horst arnold und so weiter
verschulden sie nicht mehr
selber auf twitter gesagt 2017 er möchte
da bei solchen debatten nicht mehr als
beispiel herangezogen werden sollten
auch berücksichtigen weil
also diese dieses cherry picking was
hier gerade passiert also dieses es gibt
frauen die das auch machen und die gibt
es ja natürlich gibt es das aber wenn
man sich die statistiken einfach mal
anguckt sieht man halt einfach dass die
mehrheit und zwar die massive mehrheit
anders herum passiert und dass der
jetzt ein kopfschütteln aber was ist das
ist halt die lebensrealität von frauen
und das können sie vielleicht jetzt
nicht so nachvollziehen aber deswegen
habe ich ja die empathie auch vorhin
angesprochen deswegen noch einmal
konkret zu deinem fall du bist youtube
drin und ja hass vor einigen jahr ein
video veröffentlicht indem du von
persönlichen erfahrungen mit sexueller
belästigung von zwei anderen großen
erfolgreichen youtube bereichert hast
wie war es denn für dich also was für
reaktionen hast du zum beispiel bekommen
und wie geht es dir jetzt einige jahre
später damit mit den öffentlichen
reaktion also dass ich hatte den jet
storm zweimal einmal als ich die namen
nicht genannt habt ihr jahre später als
ein früherer befreundeter kollege
einfach die namen ungefragt gejobbt hat
in der öffentlichkeit und dann ging also
die ganze sache noch mal richtig hoch
und das war intensiv weil ich habe drohe
nachrichten bekommen ich habe das selber
ja auch gar nicht entschieden also es
waren eigentlich durchgängig immer nur
über griffigkeit von männern mir
gegenüber obwohl ich mich nie als opfer
gefühlt habe sondern eigentlich stark
sein wollte und dagegen vorgehen wollte
ich wollte sensibilisieren und aufklären
und was ich dafür bekommen habe war am
ende des tages
pass und zwar ziemlich viel an glaubst
du dass das was wir gerade erzählt hat
der grund ist warum vielen frauen das
überhaupt so schwer fällt das öffentlich
zu machen also genau diese reaktion
absolut weil wir hatten ja eben schon
angesprochen
da diese männer nehmen sich dann auch in
der form diese sicherheit weil sie
wissen es gibt kastens eine
rechtsprechung unrechtssystem dass sie
in der regel wie auch die zahlen die so
genannte sie schützt die wissen was sie
schützen die schützen sich gegenseitig
wir hatten das auch bei diversen anderen
fällen wo dann andere promis auch
angefangen haben und auf instagram zum
beispiel zu schreiben ich bin hinter dem
brauch ich bin auf jeden fall hinter die
durch sind dass diese befürchtung da
geht es nicht und das stichwort auch
digitale welt so die dritte der
gleichstellungsbericht der
bundesregierung übrigens sehr
interessant sagt ja auch wer zum
beispiel in sozialen medien vor allem
repräsentiert das das sind meistens
weise zu sexuellem männer die
repräsentiert sind und es gibt aber auch
zahlen wonach eben viele frauen vor
allem diskriminiert werden und es gibt
eine sehr klare vorstellung zb stichwort
rollenbilder wie männer zu sein haben
wie frauen zu sein haben und wien er
diese ganze gleicht das heißt wir müssen
uns schon die frage stellen es gibt es
gibt ängste und ich bin auch voll
brauchen angstfreien raum das ist das
wichtigste
aber diese angstfreien raum der muss
erst mal nicht nur von den leuten
gedacht gedacht und
auseinandergetrieben und strukturiert
werden die eigentlich für diese ängste
nicht zuständig sind und deshalb denke
ich das ist ein wichtiger schritt da
anzufangen weil männlichkeit als teil
des problems
das größte problem dieser ganzen debatte
sorgt ist aber ich habe mir nur überlegt
wie es wohl sein kann unter betrachtung
all diese argumente dass am beginn des
einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts frauen in diese formate
gehen wie der bachelor stark
sexualisiert wie in einem harem sich
einem manne anbieten um als größten
traum zu erleben wie sie aus der masse
heraus gepickt werden mit der
entscheidungsmacht eines einzelnen
mannes wie lässt sich denn das dann
einordnen ist ja auch eine spiegelung
unseres zeitgeistes ich verstehe jetzt
gerade die frage wie ist das vereinbar
dass frauen das andererseits tun während
wir doch dankbar sind um die hashtag me
to debatte aber das ist einfach nur eine
sendung die die traditionelle sicht
bestätigt und darauf bin deswegen ist
das jahr für frauen sorgen sich eben in
einem schnellen prozess natürlich ist
das was diese wie gesagt hat mit diesen
formaten
weil sich sat 1 rtl 2 wo auch immer das
läuft das markierten fast alles
verständnis dieser rollen unterschiede
und wenn wir sagen wenn wir nach
gemeinsamkeiten suchen dann müssen wir
doch sagen
wollen wir eine gesellschaft haben eine
liberale in der das eine option ist und
wir lassen das zu weil es eben frauen
männer gibt die das irgendwie okay
finden und wir wollen aber gleichzeitig
eine andere gesellschaft haben wie
moderieren wir so ein prozess ohne dinge
zu verbieten wie gestalten einen
kulturellen wandel ohne andere position
ab zu werden ich habe mehr fragen als
lösungen wenn sich diese wenn man wenn
eine gruppe von männern oder von
privilegierten männern oder wenn die der
position sind eben frauen das leben
schwer zu machen eben und auch diese
mikrowelle zu produzieren bereit wäre
ein schritt beiseite zu treten und ihre
ihrer position zurückweichen und zu
sagen okay wir machen jetzt platz und
wir wollen wirklich etwas ändern
absurd aber dann stellt sich diese frage
gar nicht mehr wo wir die bereiche
rechte beschneiden weil das würde sich
dann das würde sich dann aus höflichkeit
und aus menschenfreundlichkeit ein
verfügen weil wenn sich diese nennen
wirs toxisch männlichkeit bewegen würde
würden sich viele dieser fragen von
alleine gar nicht mehr stellen dann
würden wir nämlich sagen okay gender
gerechte sprache weil wir wollen
freundlich und respektvoll mit allen
unseren mitmenschen seien mehr
feministische positionen weil wir wollen
breiter diskutieren weniger sexistische
werbung weil wir wollen niemanden
gefühle verletzen wir schon gar nicht
die von frauen und das wäre das hat dann
nichts mehr mit liberalen
grundprinzipien zu tun sondern einfach
wie weit verletzten wir unsere
mitmenschen oder nicht oder wie weit
waren wir auch deren
rechte und und deren integrität also die
gesellschaft organisiert sich selber
dorthin nur weil bei werbung wenn wir
das problem dieser toxischen
männlichkeit angehen dann würden sich
eben viele dinge neu gruppieren und
fügen ich muss jetzt mal was zur
toxischen männlichkeit sagen
männlichkeit
kann eigentlich nicht toxisch sein
dieser begriff hat sich ja jetzt geprägt
der wird benutzt das ist auch
funktioniert auch einigermaßen dennoch
wenn wir jetzt so häufig dass hier
fallen lassen zusammen mit
menschenfreundlichkeit es gibt einen
fachbegriff in der psychoanalyse das
heißt über männlichkeit hyper
maskulinität
und das ist etwas was in der kulturellen
genetik bei uns sehr sehr tief verankert
ist in der regel ist es ganz banal und
nicht so theoretisch wie ist jetzt
angefangen habe der kleine junge ist zu
hause er ist nur unter frauen die männer
sind weg der vater fährt mit großen lkw
auf einer großen autobahn er führt ein
großes medienhaus
oder er bediene gefährlich kreissäge
irgendetwas was für den kleinen jungen
in dem moment wo er merkt dass er nicht
ein mädchen ist wie die meisten um ihn
herum die mütter die tanten die
kindergärtnerinnen die
grundschullehrerinnen und mittlerweile
auch die mittelstufen lehrerin und der
stellt sich möglichkeit als etwas
gigantisches vor und kriegt
er glaubt das kann er nicht erreichen
und genau dieser zusammenhang
führt dazu dass hinterher ein verhalten
auftritt dass wir taktisch nennen und
auch tatsächlich toxisch ist vor allem
auch für diese jungs oder jungen männer
glaubst du denn dass dann vielleicht
genau mit dem also mit dem was du gerade
ansprichst mit auch eine chance für
männer sein kann sich selbst zu
sensibilisieren und so das eigene
verhalten zu reflektieren absolut da
kann ich den kreis schließen zu
übergriffe gegen männer die geschlechts
grenze ist in need to gefallen das war
vorher nicht der fall dass auch männer
über übergriffe reden konnten also von
männern auf männer sowieso oder auf
jungs aber auch von frauen auf männern
gibt es einige sehr gute beispiele und
das begrüße ich sehr deswegen bin ich
für die für den ganzen feminismus
dankbar bin auch für diese mit bewegung
sehr sehr dankbar weil in der körper
politik für männer noch sehr viel zu
gewinnen ist sehen wir was müsste denn
für dich passieren dass wir wenn wir zum
beispiel in fünf jahren eine weitere 13
fragen folge zu dem thema machen du
sagen würdest ich stehe auch auf dem
gelben fällt im sinne von ich
unterstütze die these zu sagen ja wir
haben eigentlich jetzt schon ziemlich
viel erreicht so traurig dass jetzt aus
meinem mund klingt find ich das relativ
unrealistisch dass das innerhalb von
fünf jahren passiert weil es braucht ja
noch ein bisschen bis die nächsten
generation erwachsen werden und was
verändern können und natürlich können
wir verschiedene werkzeuge nutzen wie
zum beispiel mieter also ich sehe diese
bewegung tatsächlich als ein werkzeug um
zu sensibilisieren
also dass wir einfach darauf aufmerksam
gemacht werden dass es diese fälle gibt
und dass wir miteinander reden und
empathisch aufeinander reagieren das
heißt ich habe nicht nur mit freundinnen
dank der mito bewegung über all das was
das umfasst geredet sondern auch mit
männlichen freunden denen dann auf
einmal offen für diese themen waren und
auf mich zugegangen sind und ich glaube
wenn man miteinander redet dann versteht
man auch die andere seite besser und
kann besser empathie entwickeln und
dadurch können männer auch ganz leicht
erkennen ist das jetzt eine über
griffigkeit weil mein gegenüber so und
so reagiert wenn man sieht das ja
eigentlich also ich muss dafür ja
eigentlich nicht sprechen man merkt das
ja eigentlich aber in empathie
entwickelt wird der serie was würdest du
denn sagen was müsste eine
frauenbewegung in zukunft also wenn wir
jetzt noch mal in die zukunft gucken zum
abschluss dieser diskussion anders oder
besser machen als zum beispiel metro
also wenn man jetzt zum beispiel eine
neue frauenbewegung denkt oder er anders
machen als bisher um machtmissbrauch
besser bekämpfen zu können ohne mit
würden wir hier gar nicht stehen und
diese debatte diese dinge überhaupt
erstmal zu benennen und mit allen
aspekten zu beleuchten ist ja schon ein
erster sehr guter anfang womit frauen
auf dem weg zu ihrer unabhängigkeit aber
nicht gerechnet haben das ist die
tatsache dass das alte programm erhalten
geblieben ist denn wann immer auch was
schiefgeht sie soll dann doch die tolle
gastgeberin sein sie darf zu hause keine
fresse ziehen sie darf keine schlechte
laune haben am besten auch ordentlich
onduliert gepflegt sein attraktiv
bleiben aber doch dann auch immer wieder
sanft weiblich und da finde ich ist das
wichtigste
gesellschaftlicher respekt gerade von
männern für die leistung von frauen und
auf diesem weg zur unabhängigkeit alle
mögliche unterstützung die es nur gibt
denn es ist keineswegs so dass uns die
unabhängigkeit von ballast befreit hätte
stimmt ihr dazu
jetzt versuche ich noch mal weil ich so
daran interessiert wäre da so ein punkt
zu machen ich glaube die fluchtlinien
heißt noch nicht dass wir uns
auseinander dividieren sondern so
einkommen goal haben zu sehen wie sie
eine veränderte männlichkeit aus was hat
sich denn schon verändert und was du
gesagt hast mit der angst und auch was
ihr widerfahren ist
daran müssen wir uns euch das darf mich
sein daran das muss das ziel sein und da
ist das gerade schon angesprochen
einkommen und gold deswegen würde ich
jetzt gerne zu den kompromissen kommen
ich werde euch jetzt ein
kompromissvorschlag nennen und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr gerne einen schritt
auf mich zugehen und dem zustimmen wenn
nicht bleibt ihr natürlich stehen wenn
ihnen ganz schrecklich findet geht er
einen schritt zurück und danach habt ihr
noch mal die möglichkeit jeweils auf
eurem fällt euch ein kompromissvorschlag
für die andere seite zu überlegen die
ihr dann der anderen seite vorschlag und
dann mal schauen ob ihr noch einen
weiteren schritt aufeinander zugeht oder
nicht elfte frage von 13 fragen können
wir uns darauf einigen dass im fünften
jahr mito zwar nicht alles beim alten
ist also beispielsweise viele schon 14 7
sensibilisiert hat und wie wir gerade
besprochen haben aber deutsche
unternehmen machtmissbrauch aktuell
immer noch viel zu wenig offen legen und
ahnten wir sind hier also noch relativ
am anfang wenn ihr mir dazu stimmt
könnte ein schritt auf mich zugehen denn
die händler stehen am anfang ja wir sind
am anfang dann kannst du einen schritt
auf mich zugehen wenn du möchtest
ihr seid auch ein start mit zugang nicht
hast schon da bin ich jetzt noch weiter
nach vorn ich bin ja immer nach vorne
bleibt stehen aber stimmt zu ich habe
dazu ja wirklich hinreichend viel gesagt
dann rechne ich euch jetzt gerne dazu
einladen jeweils auf eurem fällt euch
einen kompromissvorschlag zu überlegen
wir hoffen
es wird alles muss verständlich
okay das war jetzt auf jeden fall schon
bis hierhin eine ziemlich hitzige
diskussion ich bin gespannt was jetzt
hier gleich noch für
kompromissvorschläge kommen und falls
ihr jetzt geradezu guckt und ich denke
ich habe noch den ultimativen
kompromissvorschlag der jetzt eigentlich
kommen müsste dann schreibt ihn gerne in
die kommentare
[Musik]
was ist euer kompromissvorschlag an das
grüne feld schwache männer brauchen
starke frauen
das ist der kompromiss ja ok
könnt ihr das vielleicht ein bisschen
aus formulieren was er damit meint
benutzen welche männer haben es nötig
auf diese weise sich die liebe oder die
erotik einer frau zu erschleichen oder
zu erhan dlm zu agilen angebote dieser
art zu machen
es macht doch die männer sehr klein wenn
sie es für nötig halten auf diese weise
die liebe oder die begierde einer frau
sich zu sichern also es wäre im grunde
genommen das gedankenexperiment darin
vor allem die defizitäre form von
männlichkeit zu sehen wie das braucht
und die idee wäre wenn man kulturelle
role models weiter verändern will zu
sagen
wenn das eine defizitäre ist ein anderer
ausdruck als toxisch aber da fehlt was
oder da ist etwas missing dann wäre es
interessant wie wir dahin kommen
weil und das ist jetzt das wort von der
sed nicht von mir ich will es noch
versuchen so zu artikulieren dass es
eigentlich
englische wochen eine emblem von
männlichkeit gibt die in kommt zu einer
souveränität die sowas vom selbstbild
hielt
ausschließt und dieser blick sehen wir
jetzt gerade formuliert haben der ist
postpark reiche also das was ich von der
anderen seite gehört habe war mir immer
so ein bisschen vereinbar nehmen ein
bisschen zu sehr
schuldlos auf der männlichen seite
anschluss auf der weiblichen seite und
das halte ich für eine neuauflage des
patriarchalen blicks wir brauchen genau
das was jetzt meine partner hier gesagt
haben meine partnerin mein partner
diesen blick darauf welche schwäche in
die
vermeintlichen und echten macht
missbräuchen auch liegt okay dann könnt
ihr euch jetzt entscheiden ob ihr einen
schritt auf die gelbe seite zu gehen
möchte doch bestehen bleiben wollt ob er
einen schritt zurück gehen möchte
[Gelächter]
warum warum ist er so schwer gerade ich
glaube es liegt vielleicht einen
gewissen formulierungen ich glaube was
im kern wo ich glaube ich finde weil es
weil ich ja auch viel über männlichkeit
rede es brauche auf jeden fall eine
intensive eine radikalere
diskussion und auch veränderungen von
männlichkeit wie sie gerade ist und wir
sind sich darüber einig dass jetzt
gerade wie männlichkeit ist auf jeden
fall zum problem beiträgt und wenn ich
das so verstehe dann sage ich auf jeden
fall ja wir müssen mehr über
männlichkeit reden und ja männlichkeit
muss sich verändern im idealfall
abschaffen oder herrschafts kategorie
gar nicht überflüssig werden ok dann
könnt ihr gerne jetzt auch ein
kompromissvorschlag
rosa kompromiss vorschlag lautet wir
leben in einer frauenfeindlichen wieso
gegen gesellschaft der zum beispiel
der arbeit immer noch nicht groß
thematisiert wird oder fast
totgeschwiegen wird in der es frauen
gewisse grundrechte vorenthalten bleiben
und was jetzt passieren müsste ist dass
frauen diesen kampf also diese auch
diese den kampf durch die politischen
institutionen nicht alleine gehen müssen
sondern dass vielmehr initiative von den
männern kommen muss um diese
gesellschaft zu verändern und eben die
dafür zu sorgen dass es eben diese mito
fälle nicht mehr gibt
ihr könnt euch jetzt gerne dazu
positionieren geht er einen schritt auf
die grüne seite zu ja ich finde ich
würde es gerne machen wenn ich den
letzten teil für sich nehme da bin ich
sofort dabei ich finde die
bestandsaufnahme ist schon sehr
holzschnittartig und
also
ich finde wir müssen aufpassen dass wir
nicht in an pauschalisierungen ersticken
es gibt auch nicht die männlichkeit es
gibt auch nicht die messebühne
gesellschaft in die frauenfeindliche
umfeld sondern es gibt ja selbst in
einem unternehmen wenn es gibt selbst in
einem kulturellen kontext gibt es immer
die und die und wenn man alles sozusagen
bausch und bogen so also mit seiner
düsteren
gegenwarts analyse kann ich nichts
anfangen also wenn da so ein bisschen
mehr zuversicht und aufbruch drin wäre
dann bin ich da sofort dabei weil in der
tat was nicht passieren darf dass man es
zum thema der frauen macht das ist
grotesk es ist das thema der männer und
dann auch der frauen und ich finde wenn
man das gemeinsam annimmt und deswegen
haben wir von defizitärer männlichkeit
gesprochen die sowas überhaupt macht
oder braucht und wenn man das anerkennt
und dann den gemeinsamen weg skizziert
in allen unterschieden dann würde ich
mich sehr freuen dann hat auch diese
diskussion bei allen
unterschiedlichkeiten viel gebracht ich
fand die diskussion
ok spannend
manchmal
haben wir glaube ich nicht den bogen
geschafft wirklich komplett die
gesellschaftliche tiefe zu gehen also
wir hätten wahrscheinlich noch früher
ansetzen müssen bei bei grundsätzlichen
debatten in welchem umfeld bewegen wir
uns und auch einfach gewisse
begrifflichkeiten vor erklären sollen
dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich tiefer
diskutieren können das war so mein
eindruck mich hat gestört dass diese
diskussion sehr humorfrei war wir leben
in einer welt die jungen mädchen sind
aufgewachsen mit sex in the city sie
himmeln die kardashians an die
kardashians haben die welt verändert und
sind glaube ich da
weiter dicke passions der als grosses
sexsymbole gelten glaube ich würden so
eine debatte gar nicht führen weil sie
dekaden weiter sind und ich kann mich
mit denen komischerweise identifizieren
weil ich auf einen mann der mir diese
einladungen aus spricht mit mitleid
herabschauen würde hat sie noch einen
punkt hat der heute vielleicht zu kurz
gekommen ist oder der euch wichtig ist
dann schreibt das gerne in die
kommentare und falls ihm mehr von diesen
diskussionen sehen wollt dann könnt ihr
hier sehr gerne den kanal abonnieren
hier oben gibt es ein weiteres video zum
thema und hier unten ein weiteres video
von 13 fragen